während donald trumps anhänger wie hier
in florida über unerwartet klare siege
ihres kandidaten jubeln blickt alle welt
gespannt auf pennsylvania to close to
call weil millionen von briefwahl
stimmen noch nicht ausgezählt sind
vielleicht erleben wir dass pennsylvania
2020 das flora von 2000 war
wir erinnern uns 2004 oder extrem
umkämpft als würde ich an dem abend
ausgezählt sondern es war auch dort ein
rechtlicher kampf der bis hoch in den
supreme court in den obersten
gerichtshof gegangen ist donald trump
will nicht wahr
lange bevor ergebnisse vorliegen erklärt
er sich zum wahlsieger und nennt die
laufende auszählung eine schande
das ist diebstahl am amerikanischen volk
und peinlich für das land
wir waren auf gutem weg zu gewinnen
ehrlich gesagt haben wir die wahl
gewonnen
doch auch am abend nach der wahl gibt es
noch immer kein offizielles ergebnis
einige bundesstaaten zählen noch und für
beiden ist das rennen längst nicht
gelaufen
das ist was viele als albtraum szenario
beschrieben haben es könnte am ende
alles an einem start liegen wie
pennsylvania aufgrund der pandemie und
weil so viele menschen per briefwahl
abgestimmt haben
das phänomen dass sich jetzt in
pennsylvania michigan und wisconsin
zeigt nennen experten die red mirage
eine frühe führung für donald trump
durch wähler die an die urne die doch je
mehr briefwahlstimmen ausgezählt werden
desto weiter holt beiden auf
wenn die joe biden kampagne darauf
schaut und sagt und hört wie das weiße
haus jetzt auch anfängt zu argumentieren
diese stimmen sollen nicht mehr
ausgezählt werden
ich kann mir nur vorstellen dass die
auch sämtliche juristen die sich schon
vorher auch auf abruf mitgenommen haben
jetzt auch darauf ansetzen zu sagen das
muss gestoppt werden wir müssen
sicherstellen dass diese ganzen stimmen
ausgezählt werden
genau das will donald trump verhindern
noch in der wahlnacht kündigt der
präsident an die auszählung juristisch
stoppen zu wollen
wir werden vor den supreme court ziehen
wir wollen dass die abstimmung gestoppt
wird wir wollen nicht dass sie um vier
uhr morgens irgendwelche stimmen finden
und dazu zählen um zwei uhr morgens ruft
donald trump zur pressekonferenz kurz
nachdem fox news der hauskanal des
präsidenten als einziger sender joe
biden zum sieger in arizona ausgerufen
die wahrheit ist doch er kann den
supreme court gar nicht direkt anrufen
die auszahlung ist ja nicht einmal
beendet danach könnte es zu
rechtsstreitigkeiten kommen sehr knapp
ist zb oder wenn es darum geht ob das
automatische nachzahlungen für jeden
stimmzettel gibt mit seiner drohung
erfüllt trump jedoch genau das szenario
auf dass er seine anhänger seit monaten
vorbereitet hat die wahlen sind
gefälscht wahlfälschung gewinnen können
sie nur mit einer gefälschten wahl
das war natürlich schon teil das
argument dass wir uns heute abend auch
gesehen haben
damals hat er gesagt hat privat stimmen
sollen auch nicht mehr gezählt werden
die nach der wahl jetzt noch irgendwie
mit in den prozess mit reingenommen
werden sollen sofern das ist im
endeffekt eine erzählung die schon weit
vor der wahl los ging und jetzt heute an
zum höhepunkt gekommen ist worauf wir in
den kommenden tagen achten müssen ist ob
das fass überläuft wenn manche kein
vertrauen mehr in den politischen
prozess haben
deshalb sind aussagen wie die von
präsident trump so besorgniserregend
weil sie weiter öl ins feuer gießen
im jahr der pandemie und der
massenproteste und nach einer wahl die
amerikas spaltung deutlich zementiert
hat die hängepartie um das höchste amt
im land das potenzial eine
verfassungskrise auszulösen ich glaube
natürlich dass die situation in den usa
extrem angespannt ist dass leute sich
ein wahlergebnis wünschen
je länger das dauert je länger das auch
in die gerichtsprozesse mit reingeht das
polarisiert da ist natürlich auch die
stimmung im land und es kann natürlich
dann auch explodieren amerika braucht
eine schnelle lösung
die verfassung gibt den staaten dafür 35
tage zeit
am 8 dezember dem sogenannten safe
harbor day müssen die 538 wahlmänner
benannt werden eine woche später am 14
dezember wählen sie dann den neuen oder
alten präsidenten der vereinigten
staaten damit der am 20 januar vor dem
capitol vereidigt werden kann
[Musik]